this is what my girlfriend did one night
when i was driving home this is how much
they manipulate
or as i call it lie to get what they
want i was driving home and i was
looking at this [ __ ] there was this
diner
and i was driving home and it was late
and i was like you know hey you know i'm
gonna stop there i'm gonna get one of
those milkshakes
and you were just like oh my god
when you do that [ __ ] you it's hilarious
let's not forget at the end of the day
my job is to make those people laugh
okay nia you don't understand these
people work hard all week
these are americans they need to come
out and forget about their problems no
whatever i i don't have what am i mel
blank i got one [ __ ] voice
i do nice reference i watch cartoons
really is that all it takes to impress
you on a first date that's how you ended
up with me
he knows who does the voice of bugs
bunny this guy's a keeper
i think this guy will be able to provide
what the first night hung out
when i hooked up we'll save that for
another one okay but you got it you
gotta tell me huh
you had to be impressed with my skills
yeah yeah well
yes you see that they just won't give it
up this guy was [ __ ] [ __ ] blocking me
on an olympic level
he saw i was gonna hook up he actually
tried to split a cab with you
yeah i know on the way home and i got
around that
yeah got around that what happened i
[ __ ] put the cards
i went all in just like world series of
poker i went all
[ __ ] in she she was trying to be all
coy with a little sammy davis jr hat on
trying to play all hard to get huh
thinking you were dealing with the
sophomore in [ __ ] college like i
didn't have any [ __ ] lines
yeah and that douchebag kept coming over
[ __ ] blocking me he invited we we were
all set i was hanging out i'ma tell
right now we were hanging out
right me and this other dude and all of
a sudden nia shows up right and i can
see i can see the vibe
i see the look on her face i know she
wants it now
i can i just you know shut up you look
great you came up you had a nice big
smile
and you're being flirtatious and i
immediately liked you right
so you went to the bathroom you're with
a friend i'm with a friend
every guy knows what you're supposed to
do take that [ __ ] battle axe
out of the picture okay
take one for the team i can't remember
who the [ __ ] you're with so if it's one
of your friends i apologize
um whatever all right a uh war memorial
um so what is this [ __ ] he goes the
opposite route
i said you went to bathroom i said
listen i'm really doing well with this
girl all right so uh
dude i had to like he was like a chick
no i had to be like so if i'm not paying
attention to you don't get upset this is
how like female this dude was right
so i [ __ ] he is what he ends up doing
okay
the [ __ ] guy ends up as we're going
to leave
you know i'm thinking okay he's going to
try to peel off with your girl who's not
a battle axe and he just goes
he invites another dude over and goes
hey you guys all want to get something
to eat
remember and remember and he invited us
over now we're sitting there
it's me you you're not so battle axe
friends and three other [ __ ] [ __ ]
are sitting there and i'm trying to hit
on you
and he keeps jumping in then he goes hey
nia where do you live
oh i live up that way you want to split
a cab
remember that and i had to be like no
no no you didn't it was over at that
point i had i made the move remember
that i said you least i thought before
he [ __ ] said that
[ __ ] he was doing everything i remember
i didn't have any cash and i pulled out
my credit card
i said you guys just give me the cash or
just put it on my credit card and he
goes oh he's just trying to get the
miles
remember that anything could do to make
me look like a
i thought [ __ ] were like bam i'm
paying for the whole meal
no no no no they gave me money because i
didn't have any cash
this is how i got you but you were
sitting there and i said look
are we at least going to be able to
split a cab because i wanted to go over
and have a drink with you
right i was like at least be able to
split a cab and then you like why why do
you want to split a cab
just putting up the roadblock and that's
when i went all in i said cause i want
to kiss you
bam right yeah and then that was it i
didn't [ __ ] talk to you after that
yeah you sat there with that little
stunned look on your face then what
happened we walked outside
them then then then we walked out that
was the [ __ ] that was one of the
greatest
i i used to the [ __ ] guys like that
used to always get me i [ __ ] nailed
that
stuck the landing like a male mary lou
retton
and you know what the best part was then
i stood up we all
and i at that point i was like [ __ ] it i
said what i wanted to do
all this [ __ ] is in i don't need to talk
to her anymore and i sort of peeled off
right and then everybody got up to leave
and then you kind of tugged me on the
shoulder said don't worry she go
you say like don't worry we're going to
split a cab up time and then i'm like oh
this is going to be great
because now i'm in and now i'm going to
get you get to watch that little [ __ ]
cockblock
get his balls knocked on this on the on
the [ __ ] sidewalk and that's what
happened he came out right
he clapped his hands remember that came
out just like that
he was like so you guys ready to go and
you were like uh yeah actually we're
taking a cab
and he was and he was so in [ __ ] block
mode he still didn't know he's like no
i live right near you and you're like
listen we're taking a cab
and we're going uptown you leaned over
and you said it and then that's when he
realized
that everyone realized he was a
cockblock blocking douche and then what
did he do he goes oh oh yeah yeah i mean
yeah
he just [ __ ] peeled off yeah huh
then what happened we can't talk about
that
my other [ __ ] classic line where i
[ __ ] reeled you in was a masterpiece
[ __ ] masterpiece then we got in the
cabin and you said i thought i thought
you were going to kiss me
and we [ __ ] driving like a maniac and
i go i can't the cab's jumping around
too much
i go i'll kiss you at the first red
light right
drag it out you were trying to make this
whole like i was [ __ ] seducing you
and it worked
right then we hit the [ __ ] red light
i put one on you bam right couldn't feel
your [ __ ] feet
i'm gonna make this story last nine
hours long and then you know what
happened
then i sat back and i was playing mr
[ __ ] cool again like i'm [ __ ] walt
frazier in 1972.
oh the callback to the knicks from an
hour ago right
then what happened we stopped again and
i'm sitting there looking out the window
and you go it's another red light
right now and then and then we heard
that cheesy saxophone from every [ __ ]
sexy movie
in the 80s right
and then you were going i'm not going
home with you i'm not going home with
you now whenever they say that guys
you know they're not going home with you
you know that [ __ ] so what you have to
do
is you have to constantly make them feel
like it's
safe and they're in control so but
actually before you said
you weren't going home with me i felt
your vibe i knew the deal
so i just said listen i know we're not
going home together but i'm really
having a good time with you
i'd like to have another drink with you
all right i know a nice bar
and bam right and i did not go home
you didn't go home with me we had like
[ __ ] eight more drinks
and made out for like the next five
hours in that [ __ ] hell's kitchen bar
had a great time
there you go so there's a little story
people there's your little back story
[Music]
[Music]
you